what's going on guys this is Rob and
it's been a while since we covered in
Indie comic so we're going to cover one
here this is called the trouble with
love and it's by a friend of mine Victor
Dandridge and it's drawn by a guy named
Harold Edge who I've never met but the
thing here is that this is a Kickstarter
and those of you guys who have been
around the channel long enough you know
I never cover kickstarters unless it's
someone that I actually know and that
I'm for the most part friends with
there's the occasional exception but
very rarely does that ever happen now
the trouble with love this is one of the
things I love about this comic the whole
thing takes place in a room and this is
only the first issue right I love Comics
like this like in DC Comics the fight
between the flash Barry Allen and
reverse flash which takes place in the
amount of time it takes for a waitress
to drop a cup of coffee and for it to
hit the ground and like that Split
Second they have this crazy long drawn
out fight I think it's like a cup of
coffee but what this does here is this
opens up with basically the Superman of
this story a guy named Apex Prime and
the thing here is that he kind of has
this bit of an opening statement where
he talks about how he's had all kinds of
enemies all over the course of his life
he's fought people from a wide array of
different walks of life and he says but
there's one enemy that he's never been
able to beat no matter how hard he tried
and that enemy is love and that's what's
so crazy about it because he's kind of
given to us as this guy that almost kind
of has this cynical perception of Love
itself and he says the trouble with love
is you cannot punch it in the face now
the person he's talking to is his son
John who literally has a gun pulled on
him and is about to help this guy finish
with all his living right he's sitting
there smoking a pipe his son's about to
make it his last one but the thing about
this is he literally kind of talks his
son down for a minute but his son is
coming to this from a place of like
anger and wrath over what his father did
and the reality here is that his father
abandoned the family literally Superman
right the Superman type character
abandoned his family and it's not one of
these things where he had to like take
off to fight some enemy out in space and
like Duty called anything like that it
was never anything like that in fact
it's way more human and that's one of
the things that I love about this is the
story as it progresses because I want to
say Victor is a good chunk into like the
whole story itself right there's more to
it than just this but the nature of this
guy you do get to see his powers on
display and all that kind of stuff but
it's such a visceral and human type of
story that it's it's it's amazing right
so like the thing about this is that his
son kind of lashes out now context clues
you can obviously tell this is gonna
have some adult themes in it right some
adult language we're gonna censor all
that stuff out you know because we try
to keep it kid friendly here as best we
can we've been doing a terrible job of
it recently
but the thing here is that his son
literally refers to basically Apex
Prime's new girl uh and using some
Choice words right and that's when Apex
Prime kind of freaks out and says look
you can talk to me however you want to
but you cannot talk about her in that
way and he says I don't like I I don't
know what to tell you that will make you
forgive me right I don't know what to
tell you that will put you in a place
where you will understand why I did what
I did but the best thing that I can do
is just explain it to you now this is
where the human element comes into play
because what you're going to see over
the course of this is that despite all
these crazy powers that this guy has
super strength super speed he calls it
Blazer Vision but it's basically heat
vision but where he has like all these
different powers at the end of the day
he's just like you and me and anybody
else right human beings we are
hypocritical and we're chaotic and we're
messy and in a lot of ways even just
within the confines of like the realm of
superheroes Superman himself and various
Heroes who had kind of been modeled
after the concept are almost kind of
placed in this sort of holier than thou
ethereal role right where there's
somehow everything that we could ever
Aspire and hope to be and even the
nature and like his Form and Function of
Superman is that way this guy is kind of
the opposite right I mean he does what
superheroes do right he's going off on
this Mission with these crazy science
thing that's going nuts and stuff's
about to blow up and it's going to wipe
out of town you know and all that kind
of stuff and just doing the superhero
Thing of like stepping in and doing what
he's supposed to do right saving the day
but in the midst of all of this as he's
kind of leaving moving away from the
whole thing he ends up coming across a
woman who flashes a smile at him the two
of them have a couple words and that's
it now that's the funny thing here right
because for those of you guys who are
younger right who are who are younger
and and you haven't quite experienced
the world yet people will tell you that
love is an emotional thing and to a
degree it kind of is but the reality
here is there's a big difference between
like love and infatuation infatuation is
an emotional response love is a choice
and that where initially Apex Prime just
kind of saw this girl flashing a smile
towards him and just kind of pushing it
out of his head and focusing on
superhero Antics the reality is he just
couldn't get this girl out of his head
he goes home to his wife he goes home to
his family but he can't let this girl go
now the funny thing here is initially
again he kind of dismisses it but he
sort of introduces this idea of Fate now
you can interpret this in a couple of
different ways right it's like the 2023
definition of what we call human nature
right it's just the stuff that we don't
want to deal with right like what you
know is it's it's human nature guys of
only there was something we could do
about it right you know but we can't but
the reality here is that even within the
confines of this whole situation he kind
of bounces back and forth between this
idea of I couldn't get this girl out of
my head it was just something about her
right at any point in time he could have
just said no he could have just stopped
it and just said nope that's it done
gone that's never gonna happen right
it's a choice that he made to lean into
it and he kind of pushes it into the
responsibility of Fate right kind of
absolving himself of his perspective and
simply saying well you know she kept
popping up it was fake man it was fate
right we were meant to be together right
and so kind of justifying his actions by
almost sort of blaming this concept
that's so far beyond the realm of human
understanding that it just kind of moves
in mysterious ways and we're all bound
to it and governed by it and so it just
kind of puts him in a situation where
it's like there's nothing I could do
right and so what ends up happening is
that where she initially meets him and
then he just flies off right where she
shows up as a because it turns out she's
a cop she shows up she gets his
attention and he just takes off that
could have been the end of it instead he
goes back to her right and he says look
I owe you a apology for how I responded
before and he even says I had to know
what I was running from right like being
a hero I've encountered extraordinary
circumstances and influential Powers
before but it wasn't it was real as real
as you or I in this room and it was
Mutual she was infatuated with him he
was infatuated with her and even he says
I can't right I have a family I have a
wife and and I can't do this and so he
says maybe I was naive to think we could
just be that but I wanted to try if only
to keep her in my life but I should have
known better and so even when he gets
back home after spending the day with
Angie his wife's just kind of like hey
you're finally home how was everything
you know kind of falling asleep in the
process he's like yeah there was there
was a Stampede in central Africa and you
know a village almost got you know
destroyed she's like oh that's nice and
then just kind of falls asleep but one
of the things to know is it's not as
though his wife was neglectful but it's
not like it was one of these things
where she was only there for the good
times and the good times and like that
was it she was really a dutiful wife you
know she was there for him in every way
that seemingly a wife would be and so
him taking this approach the reality
here is that if we want to kind of
reduce this down to simplify terms of
good guys and bad guys then sure he's
the bad guy here but what this all
really points to is the general gist
that as people we are chaotic
hypocritical messy but what he tells his
son is I loved your mother very deeply
for so long she was my best friend my
Confidant I thought she'd be the only
person on Earth I could be completely
honest with about who I am and what I do
never in a million years did I think
someone else would be that for me but
there she was again the whole thing here
is it's not my fault I mean it kind of
is because I guess I maybe I could have
said no but I didn't say no because some
power greater than myself was was kind
of pulling the strings here right and so
he says between the two of them they
were having these very close and
personal intimate conversations it
started off small right the two of them
exercising together spending time
together talking together right but he
says that level of honesty breeds
intimacy such and intense having like
these genuine and true and personal
conversations with someone else you have
to be able to put up this kind of
artificial barrier in your mind you have
to be able to say sure I'm having a
personal conversation with this person
but they could be anybody right and I
have to view it that way they are not my
partner right they don't see my partner
or see me the way my partner does I
don't see them the way I see my partner
and it's a choice that I make the thing
about this is that the more time they
spend together and the more time they
socialize together the more that he
begins to fall more and more in love
with her to the point that they actually
end up sleeping together and he says I
had grown so used to living a double
life that creating this third one came
easy he says we didn't call ourselves
anything Angie hated thinking about
being the quote unquote other woman and
I wasn't so keen on it either we
accepted the way things were because we
were happy being together at all but I
do know her one regret was not meeting
you now this is kind of the irony of the
whole situation is because it's not
necessarily Apex in this picture that
like Angie is some kind of a victim here
but again it really is him saying I mean
I guess on some level I was responsible
but you know if we're talking about
percentages here I was like 10
responsible fate was responsible for the
other 90 right like that kind of a thing
right the justifications that we as
humans use to make the decisions that we
make and the response of his son is to
actually lash out right to reject him
right he even says oh boo hoo she didn't
get to meet her boyfriend's kid am I
supposed to feel sorry for her now I
don't and he says I was just a kid even
I could tell that something was wrong I
didn't know or understand it but I could
feel it and so could mom and the reality
here is that while their marriage wasn't
like full of arguing and fighting and
things were falling apart it was that
feeling and anybody who's been in a
relationship and felt things falling
apart knows exactly what I'm talking
about it's the feeling that like the
foundation is kind of starting to
crumble a little bit right the person is
just sort of slowly drifting away the
conversations don't feel as intimate as
they used to you don't hold hands the
same way you used to when you kiss it
doesn't feel the same same way when
you're intimate together things just
feel a little off almost as if they're
there but they're not there at the same
time and so when you had Jon kind of
looking at his mom and seeing her in
such a vulnerable and devastated State
responsive Apex is you're right John I
should have seen it but I didn't I
couldn't I'm human super or not I'm just
a human being and I was in love truly in
love no amount of vision x-ray or
otherwise could have seen through that
not then not yet and that's when it all
hit the fan because a man of his stature
in his position is always being watched
right he's like a celebrity out there
right you have celebrities and then you
have the paparazzi who were trying to
make some semblance of a living by
taking pictures of other people now and
as soon as he's out there with Angie he
kisses her they're intimate together the
photos get shot it goes onto the front
page and that's how his wife learns his
wife learns that he was cheating on her
from tabloid magazines but the reality
here is that with him being out there
and being photographed and cheating on
his girl he literally grabs Angie and
just kind of whisks away and what he
says is from the moment that photo was
taken the Clock Was ticking would I get
to her first would one of my enemies get
to her first and he even goes out
publicly and says she's been moved to a
safe location for her own safety and he
says being with me cost her everything
her job her family I had a
responsibility to her right so Not only
was he stepping out on his family she
was stepping out on hers and then John
kind of comes back with the other half
of the story and says look I mean if
what you want to do here is play the
victim and you want to feel bad and you
want me to feel bad and you want me to
look at you as a person who was somehow
caught up by the hand of fate and if
only there was something that you could
have done if only you could have punched
a little harder or flown a little faster
or your heat vision was a little bit
hotter that maybe you could have somehow
avoided all this that's not gonna happen
because all you had to do was just say
no and that would have been it this is
really you excusing your behavior by
trying to use some justification that no
one can contend with right no one can
contest and he says Heroes protect
people and for all your talk of
protection you hurt two people who
should have mattered the most I had to
witness the mess you made I had to watch
my mother reliving the announcement of
the failure of her marriage as it was
replayed on National Television over and
over and over again you weren't even
decent enough to give her a heads up
phone call you just disappeared
literally as soon as the affair became
public knowledge Apex was just gone well
he just took off Angie was his main
focal point and that was seemingly it
but in fact it wasn't necessarily that
way right like John asked like why was
she so much more important than us why'd
you save her and leave me and Mom behind
and he says it was a lot more
complicated than that right like I
understand your perspective I really do
but you don't understand mod and so one
of the things that Apex says is that
when his wife found out about the affair
he went to go see her and she literally
lost it right she lashed out at him and
said don't ever come back here you don't
come back here you never see our son
that's never going to happen again right
you are out of our lives forever you've
made your choice and that was it and so
the thing about this is that when he
says you know well your mother gave me
no choice the response of his son is
predictable here how on one hand do you
justify your action of sync well I I had
no choice when it came to this whole
situation with Angie because fate was
pulling the strings and then on the
other hand use the same justification
with the fact that you abandoned us that
you that you never called her you never
told her you couldn't have even sat down
with her and said look I found somebody
else I want to see where this goes right
like how do you use these justifications
You Are by all standards of measurement
the least responsible person ever right
it's that kind of a thing right his
response he even lashes out at his
father and then attacks him because Jon
has the same Powers as his father and so
he says yes I lied to your mother about
me having an affair but I lied to her
again when I said that I would stop
seeing you the reality here is I would
always stop in to check on you when you
were playing your little league games I
was up in the sky watching you I was
keeping an eye on that and the response
to John is I mean I could hear your
heartbeat like I kind of figured you
were there there but it's one of these
things where it's like yes I did a
terrible thing but like you know I mean
I tried to make up for it right but
there are some things in this world that
we do that cannot be made up for there's
no way that you can do enough right to
balance out the scales it doesn't work
that way but the other part of this is
the fate of his ex-wife because what
ends up happening is Jon tells him with
everything that happened and her
watching her life fall apart in the
blink of an eye and having to live it
over and over again on National
Television she took herself out right
she overdosed and that was it you drove
my mother to end her life you did that
she never would have done that had you
not done what you did now that's the
beauty of this whole thing because over
the course of the other stories that
Victor's going to cover not everything
is what it seemed it's the perspective
of a child and one of the things to know
and and you really know this if you're
somebody my age and you live in
Nostalgia just because you remember
things being a certain way doesn't mean
they were that way it just means you
remember it being that way right and so
once Apex learns about this then it's
just kind of like okay hey I gotta bring
my son into the fold right now the other
thing that he reveals here is that the
Apex has basically had a kid right he
had a second kid and so it's one of
these things where he kind of invites
him in now the funny thing about this is
that Jon is very reluctant to all of
this right he says because when his mom
OD'd he wasn't even there when it
happened right there were so many times
when she was just on the edge and John
was able to bring her back he was able
to talk her down but the thing about
this is that in this instance when she
was at her lowest moment he was out
saving some some truck driver who'd
fallen asleep behind the wheel and he
says I was out doing superhero things I
never told her that because what I
didn't want her to know is that there
was some part of you that was still
within me I didn't want her to know that
I had your powers that I was a walking
talking mirror copy of you I hated you
that much and I knew how much it would
destroy her or at least destroy what
little she had left going for her if I
told her that but in that moment when I
was doing what you would do she ended up
dying so in a lot of ways Jon kind of
interprets this as really really just
kind of looking at his dad and saying
everything you are everything you stand
for 4 leads to nothing but death and
loss right you are literally just deaf
incarnate you bring nothing but sadness
and misery to people around you now a
lot of this is just anger and a lot of
this is just rage and that's really
where it all hits because Apex looks at
his son and says John you do realize
killing me will not bring your mother
back right you know that and the
response of John is yes and that's
really the Crux of all of this it's the
first time that John has confronted his
father once since the death of his mom
and two since he developed any semblance
of power right where he feels as if he's
man enough to be able to confront his
father on this level but at the really
the core of all of this right at the
center of all of this it's just sadness
and pain right it is a child crying out
to his father wanting to know why did
you destroy our family why did you wipe
out everything that you claim to love
why would you do this and that is really
the Crux of the Story's name the trouble
with love because it's beautiful and
wonderful as love is and while it can
bring you to the highest places
imaginable take you to levels of
exuberation and thrill that you never
thought you'd ever experience it can
bring you to the lowest lows to lows
that you didn't even know existed right
but at the end of all of this because of
what John is struggling with basically
Apex says be a part of the family
there's nothing else for you out there
now right be my son I will teach you to
become a superhero be a part of our
family meet your sister and so John
ultimately agrees and decides to come
back the next morning for breakfast with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end if you guys enjoyed it
this story is phenomenal the trouble
with love and it only gets better it
only ever gets better so we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace